Nice to economics,
what Axel rose is to the music industry,
rocks in the late eighties and the
beginning of the nineties.
Then they started losing grounds and
nowadays anytime they try to make a
comeback,
the results are pretty disappointing.
I know you're thinking of first glance.
Japan doesn't seem to be that bad,
right?
I mean they have the video games,
the enemy movies and world class tech
Bam offs and cameras or Tokyo that looks
like a city.
It's the world's biggest metropolis with
over $30 million people.
Then they have the fastest trains,
the most modern tvs and even human like
robots.
Nonetheless,
this country has gone through two
decades without any economic growth and
I saw the worst of us.
Japan is the most indebted country in
the world because they are more than
twice their entire GDP and the
population is increasing faster than
anywhere else.
Which poses a big problem when it comes
to paying for retirement pensions.
This is one of the reasons why Japanese
workers have crazy hours and almost no
vacation time and those good old
technological juggernauts like a touch
or panasonic or falling behind the more
modern companies from China and America.
Hold on a second because things,
they might be on the verge of change.
Yes.
I'm talking here about the Tokyo
Olympics.
Do you take place in 20,
20?
It's an opportunity to showcase their
entire country and get the world's
attention.
Yes.
Did you ever since Japan won the Olympic
bid in 2013,
tourism has absolutely skyrocketed
and the same goes with private
investment.
By the year 20,
20 Tokyo will have 45 brand new
skyscraper.
Nice.
Like Panasonic will set state of the art
solar cells in increasing location so
people can charge their electric cars
anywhere and if this wasn't enough,
Sony will launch their brand new eight k
TV screens.
Yes.
You had that right?
Soon enough.
We are going to have eight cases.
You can see every microfiber of the
athletes shirts,
but hold on for just a second ed,
because not everything is so beautiful.
You see,
when Tokyo won the Olympic bid,
they had budgeted six point 5 billion
American dollars,
but since they started building,
the costs have doubled and they haven't
even finished.
Yes.
In fact,
Tokyo City Hall has predicted that the
total cost might be up to around 20
billion USD,
so the question is on the Olympic Games,
actually an opportunity for Japan,
or quite the opposite,
are the Olympic Games as good for a
country's,
as people say,
well,
today we are going to answer these
questions,
but as we always do,
let's take a look.
First back at the history Olympic
fallacy.
Very few things spark national pride
quite as much as the Olympic Games.
Of course,
we all like to brag about the gold
medals on country has less water really
inflames patriotism the most.
It's becoming an Olympic host.
The excitement,
it generates this so big that everyone,
regardless of their ideology,
seems to think that organizing an event
for this length,
the country is a good thing,
but from an economic standpoint,
things up.
Not that clear.
In fact,
the arguments in favor of hosting the
Olympic Games are a little bit like,
how should we say?
Well,
there is inconsistent as a tweet,
Donald Trump,
according to a paper from the Bank of
Japan,
the effects of the Olympics are so
positive that they can be filled even
before the Olympics takes place.
More specifically the same year,
the International Olympic Committee name
Tokyo as the host city.
Many started to see Japan as the perfect
place for investment.
Remember that we're talking about a
paper from an institution as prestigious
as the Bank of Japan.
This is basically the Japanese
equivalent to the American Federal
Reserve.
That said,
one of their main arguments is that if
your city gets to the common Olympic
host,
the whole country can join all those big
organizations that every country wants
to be a member of.
So how about an example?
Well,
Barcelona got the nomination in 1986.
Some theme that very same.
Yes.
Spain joined the EU.
Beijing was nominated in 2001 and then
again they joined the World Trade
Organization that very year.
It seems like this line of reasoning is
pretty bulletproof,
but just hold on a second because this
is a textbook example of something
called correlation fallacy.
In other words,
the fact that Spain joined the EU the
same year the Barcelona got chosen as
the Olympic host does not mean that the
one thing caused the other.
In fact,
Portugal also joined the EU in the same
year and they didn't post anything
and the same will happen with China.
At the same time,
other Asian countries joined the WTO
without organizing benny sporting
events.
Now,
just hold on a second.
He's like,
probably know what you're thinking right
about now when you're probably thinking,
well,
Hey Simon,
what about other international attention
that the Olympic Games can bring?
I mean for two whole weeks the whole
world is going to have their eyes on
Japan.
That's got to be a good thing.
Rice,
I mean,
we're talking about the biggest sporting
event in the world.
Well,
maybe not.
Once you see the London Olympics in
2012,
I got a pretty average audience.
I mean around 31 million Americans.
To you,
it's
making comparison.
This is twice as much as an episode of
game of thrones and that wasn't exactly
being regarded as bas,
but well,
what about the rest of the Games now?
The Olympics in 2014 didn't even have 22
million viewers in the United States in
Rio.
20 16.
I was just 26 million,
so now these numbers might look quite
big to you right now,
but it's really nothing if we compare it
to a much cheaper events like the super
bowl.
Okay.
The 2016 superbowl surpassed a hundred
and 10 million viewers.
In other words,
even though the Olympics or watched all
around the world,
when you look at the audience,
country by country,
the figures aren't really that
impressive and this means that the
perception people have about that
country doesn't really change.
The state doesn't really seem to change
for the good.
A study of the impact of the 2000
Olympics in Sydney.
Australian researchers interviewed
people one year before and after the
games they found a little change in
perceptions with one surprising wrinkle.
South Africans were displeased with
Australia because of the way in which
the aboriginal issue was highlighted and
portrayed by the South African.
Nonetheless,
there is one thing that it seems fair to
agree on Olympic Games do.
Kickstart your tourism industry.
Actually,
since Tokyo was chosen as the Olympic
coast tourism in Japan has absolutely
skyrocketed.
I mean they almost didn't have any
tourists since 2013,
but last year they support 24 million
people.
You could say essentially a brand new
industry.
It's just been born in Japan and
tourism.
Tourism is an industry that attracts a
lot of foreign money and our money.
I mean,
got to be a good thing.
Right.
Well,
I can't just hold on a minute because
even these figures that are up for
debate,
of course tourism in Japan,
it's increased a lot,
but do you know of some other countries
that also have a booming tourist section
right now?
Well,
shelley and Thailand are great examples.
They have grown at a similar rate to
Japan and don't even Google it because
I'm going to tell you right now,
neither of these countries is planning
to host the Olympic Games anytime soon.
Did Thailand's example is pretty
paradigmatic.
They get 6 million more tourists than
Japan each year and they have just
popped population and their tourism.
Grief is directly correlated to that of
the Chinese middle class.
In other words,
as Chinese people have more money,
they want to do more sightseeing and
well,
where do they go?
Well,
they go to countries that are nearby and
it's a beautiful things to see.
All right.
All right,
so now you might be thinking,
well,
even if the Olympics aren't as
profitable as they seem,
well,
what's the problem?
If Tokyo wants to host the Olympics,
I mean he doesn't like having a giant
stadium in his city.
Well,
that's inclusive.
Look at that one too.
Medalists in spending.
Now we all know that the Olympics are
costly from one day to the next.
Okay.
Basically went from not having to have
an Olympic stadiums,
so having to have one which has to hold
more than 80,000
people and also,
I mean they have to impress everyone
with lights and colors and all sorts of
fancy things,
but it doesn't stop there.
I mean they also need other special
venues for the mini competitions that
are held at the same time.
Each of the sports has its own
specifications in total.
Thirty one venues will need to be built
or remodels for the Tokyo 20,
20 summer Olympic Games.
Yes.
And then there's a media center and
other giant white elephants ends on top
of that.
There's the Olympic villa.
The Olympic villa is basically nothing
short of a small town where 10,000
athletes are going to live during the
Olympics and as you can probably
imagine,
this is certainly not going to be cheap.
Now remember at the total cost for this,
we're supposed to be at six point 5
billion USD.
At least this was the figure given by
the local authorities to the
International Olympic Committee in 2013.
But as you know,
theories are one thing and reality is
something completely different.
Pure 20,
20 Olympic Games costs just keep rising.
By December 2017,
Tokyo City Hall had already spent over
$12,000,000,000
and just a couple of months later the
local authorities report is that they
would end up spending a whopping figure
of at least $20,000,000,000
and is even possible that this figure
will keep rising before they even begin
to burn the Olympic flame.
But I mean none of this is really a
surprise
since he can remember every Olympic game
has had significant cost overruns.
Rio De Janeiro,
2016 ended up costing 51 percent more
than expected.
But the record so far is Montreal.
Nineteen 76,
which costs 700 percent more than was
initially budgeted.
You heard that right?
Eight times more than what was first
planned.
All right,
so now you might be wondering,
well,
how these
billions of dollars really all that much
money for a big governments and you
compared with normal spending in a big
city whole,
is that actually a lot of money?
Well,
the answer to that is an absolutely
resounding yes for better understanding
with $20 million US dollars,
you could build a highway that connected
the extreme north of Japan to the
extreme south and that really isn't even
the worst of it.
You see an apple for a highway.
It can ends up being a waste of money,
but still you can always reutilize this.
A country with best,
better infrastructure and communication
can have better companies in the future.
Brand new industries,
a better public services.
What do you get with an Olympic stadium?
The Coin Heist?
80,000
people.
Well,
if we look at past examples of the
answer to that question,
it's pretty bleak.
Olympic venues already falling into a
state of disrepair.
The Rio de Janeiro example is
particularly harsh.
Despite hosting the Olympics.
They still have entire neighborhoods
that aren't even connected to the city
center by a bus line and the place where
the Olympic villa was.
Well,
that's becoming a slum and this is not
the only example.
Athens Olympic in ruins 10 years on from
the 2004 games.
Yeah,
and then you've got to add to all of
this that Japan is the most indebted
country on the planet.
They owe us some equivalent to 130
percent of their GDP to government is
already struggling to pay retirement
pensions and they've already been two
years without any economic growth
whatsoever,
but now I would say what to you?
Do you think that the Tokyo Olympics in
2020 will mean the ruin of Japan or
maybe against the odds?
Do you think Japan will benefit from
hosting the events while please leave
your answer in the comments section
below,
and if you want to know more about
Japan's failed economy,
please do click on this video.
Also to visit our friends from the
regions that immediate podcasts gotta to
reconsider media Dot Com.
This podcast provided the vocals in this
episode,
that one,
not mine,
and don't forget that we published brand
new videos every Monday and every
Thursday just like this,
so hit that subscribe button and you
won't miss a single post.
Also,
if you like this video,
please do give a thumbs up and as always
I'll see you in the next one.
I mean,
if you want to learn more about politics
and hear more of my lovely voice,
don't forget to check out the reconsider
podcast at reconsider media duck.